[Music]
hey everybody welcome to i got a
question i'm mikey i'm going to be
answering this question that came in
that said
how do i open up a conversation with
someone about the dangers of certain
media that's a good question because
inevitably this is going to come up we
are so saturated in our culture with
different types of media that you're
bound to be around somebody that says
hey why don't you go watch this movie
with me or something and it could be an
awkward situation it could be a
sensitive topic for some people but
you know if somebody's truly your friend
i think maybe they'll hear you out and
kind of understand about certain things
you know i wouldn't expect someone who's
been in
a war
to watch a war movie with me maybe it's
a triggering topic for them and and i
wouldn't pressure it well why don't you
watch it you know so that would be
something where somebody would be
understanding and sympathetic also maybe
if someone uh had had some kind of
traumatic thing happen in their life
you wouldn't expect them to watch a
movie that would bring up those types of
triggering topics so i think this is a
time where you can kind of plant a seed
and just say well i don't really want to
watch that type of movie and if they say
why not you can always say well it just
it does something to my spirit it just
it's it's full of violence it's full of
sexual immorality and these things go
against what i believe and then if the
conversation continues you can share a
little more especially if the person's a
christian and they identify with your
beliefs
jesus in matthew 5 27 and 28 said
you have heard that it was said to those
of old you shall not commit adultery but
i say to you that whosoever looks at a
woman to lust for her has already
committed adultery with her and his
heart
so jesus talks about the topic of sin
how it starts in the mind it's not just
the act of committing it with your hands
he says that if you look at a woman with
lust you've actually committed adultery
already with her and your mind he
continues to say
if your right eye causes you to sin
pluck it out and cast it from you for it
is more profitable for you that one of
your members perish than for your whole
body to be cast into hell that's matthew
5 29
so jesus is even saying that things that
you see with your eyes can cause you to
face judgment and he's warning you look
if you're having trouble with something
that you're looking at it's better for
you to just pluck out your own eye and i
don't recommend that you do that i think
that we can pray to the holy spirit to
give us victory to have victory over the
sins in our life and also the things
that we put before our eyes
one barometer you can use to judge what
you should and shouldn't put before your
eyes is does it glamorize sin
does it break any of the ten
commandments i actually heard one pastor
say that if we turned off the tv every
time that a commandment was broken you'd
probably never turn your tv on again
think about a person who's peeping a
peeping tom threw a window at a couple
in their bedroom is that a good thing
but yet we will sit there in a theater
eat popcorn and look through a window
and see the same things we're watching
sin take place on this screen and we
just justify it with well it's fictional
it's not really real but when you look
at the situation a different way where a
person is really looking in through a
window at a real act we look at it
totally different why is that you know
so i think that if you have these
friends that are trying to get you to
watch things with them i think they'll
be understanding if you just
you know approach it with a sensible
reasonable explanation like that
and psalm 101 3 it says i will set no
wicked thing before my eyes i hate the
work of them that turn aside it shall
not cleave to me
the bible is giving us good counsel
about not putting wicked things before
our eyes because the things that we
watch do have effect on us there's all
kinds of scientific reasons of how
things that you see your brain actually
thinks that you're doing that that your
brain thinks that you're actively
participating in what you are viewing
and that's exactly what jesus said that
when you look at a woman with lust
you've already committed adultery with
her in your heart i think jesus was onto
something
romans 1 32 says
who knowing the judgment of god that
they which commit such things are worthy
of death
not only do the same but have pleasure
in them that do them this verse is
saying that you don't have to actually
participate in the sins but just taking
pleasure in seeing that whether it's on
screen or maybe you're at a parade
that's glamorizing something sinful if
you're taking pleasure in that you're
just as guilty as being the one
committing it so i think it's very
important what we put in front of our
eyes and i think that we should plant
that seed into our friends and give them
something to think about as well
another thing you can do is share one of
our videos with your friend if you know
your friend is into a certain show and
we've talked about it why don't you
share it with them and say what do you
think about this and put the ball in
their court you're not saying hey i
believe this is true i think you should
stop watching this
just say hey i saw this video and it's
pretty interesting i wanted to see what
you had to think about it and get the
feedback from them and then you can have
a conversation and you have no idea
maybe that'll open up the door and you
might totally see a transformation
philippians 4 8 gives us some good
counsel it says
finally brethren whatsoever things are
true whatsoever things are honest
whatsoever things are just whatsoever
things are pure whatsoever things are
lovely whatsoever things are of good
report if there be any virtue and if
there be any praise think on these
things
so i think if you walk into your
friend's house and they're watching
something with a bunch of violence or
adultery you know you could say hey can
we can we watch something else maybe
something funny you know it doesn't mean
you can't watch anything i mean i i like
to watch funny pet videos with my
daughter and even videos about people
who are giving to the homeless and
i walked away from watching those videos
with a whole different
mindset like i went it made me it
inspired me to want to do those things
it inspired me to want to give to people
and brighten somebody else's day so
that's just proof that the media does
have an effect on you just think about
how different the world could actually
be if instead of glamorizing violence
and witchcraft and adultery on on
television if the airwaves were just
pumped out full of people doing acts of
kindness people
you know out there playing with their
kids i think the world could be a much
more beautiful place if we really
focused on those things whatsoever
things are lovely and true and beautiful
i hope this helped you guys out some
continue to give us your questions we
enjoy answering these and i hope that
this was beneficial something that you
can pass on and actually put into action
and remember
you living your life a certain way is a
seed planet that's a witness that you
can actually help transform somebody
else's life just by living out the
christian walk we love you and we'll see
you guys next time on i got a question
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign